Thank you, Mister President.
Dear leftists,
I'm very happy to take part in this debate
about democracy in Europe.
So let me give you some example of
very major democracy in Poland.
Over thousand years of,
of tradition of Polish nation.
Polish nation rejected you
dear leftists
eight times.
Eight times in a row
you have lost elections in Poland.
So get used to it because you're gonna lose again.
That's number one.
Let me give you some data about Poland
and Polish democracy.
The lowest unemployment in European Union is Poland.
The highest GDP after Covid in European Union is Poland.
One of the lowest debts in European Union is Poland.
So don't give us this rubbish
about the need of educated immigration.
As we heard yesterday,
we don't need your doctors,
we don't need your engineers.
Take them. Take them all and pay for them.
We don't need them.
You know why?
Because there is a zero terrorist attacks in Poland.
Why? Because,
because there is no illegal migration in Poland.
So don't give me this, look,
don't give me this arguments about the populism
because this is a fact.
This is your data from Eurostadt.
So we don't need your engineers,
we don't need your doctors.
Take them. Do not,
do not, do not teach us,
do not, do not teach us about democracy
because we know what the democracy is.
So learn from Poland.
Be like Poland.
Thank you very much.